so from my perspective just to give you
some context
so um to me there seems to be some
stigma so i come from the scientific
community and i really appreciate you
talking to me today
and i think the people who listen to
this include um
you know uh faculty fellow faculty
at mit and major universities and it
feels like there's some stigma
to the subject from from the scientific
community
a lot of people especially when they
hear your story are like wow this is
really interesting
but you you don't even know you one
you're afraid to talk about it and two
you don't know what the next steps are
like how can we seriously try
to think about what you saw how to think
about
how we further look for things like it
how we develop
systems and plans for how in the future
we
can immediately collect a lot more data
and try to react
uh properly you know to try to
communicate
try to uh interpret this
in the best way possible from a
scientific perspective and
i i just would love to remove
stigma from this subject uh well i think
that's the first step
we have done in this country an
absolutely terrible job with these
things so you go
and i joke you know go back to roswell
so the first reports that came out of
roswell was we have this crash flying
saucer
that's literally what came out and then
magically the next day
it's a weather balloon and they're
showing you pieces of mylar and you go
well that doesn't look like what they
showed us yesterday then you get into
project blue book you know so there's
that whole series about project blue
book but the bottom line of project blue
book is it really did two things it
investigated sightings
and it did everything it could to debunk
and disprove
to the point where it actually went to
discredit you know to make you look
so there's always been this uh this i
don't know if you'd call it an aura
around it or a mystique about ufos that
if you're talking about them they're
nuts
with ours because i'm not a i'm not a
you i'm not a ufo guy i'm not a
junkie if you ask me do i believe that
there's life
outside of earth i would say you
probably have a better chance of winning
the mega ball
lottery then we're the only planet that
has life on it in the universe it's just
the odds are against it i don't know if
you do just do the math
you have to accept because it if there
only has to be one
other planet that has life on it and
then i win
and you lose and then more and more
science is showing that there's
habitable planets out there
that yeah everything we've learned so
far and we know very little but
everything we've learned so far
about the planets out there exoplanets
earth-like planets it seems that it's
very
likely that there's life out there
intelligent life is another topic
but uh life well we we as humans you
know
and even more as americans we have this
hubris about us that says
we are it and you go not so much maybe
we're not so intelligent
um because we are it's just how we learn
so
you know our main mode of transportation
and what people figured out you know
years ago was the internal combustion
engine which led us to jet engines and
and
solid rocket fuel what if you're in
another planet where you didn't you
figured out uh the ability to
create a gravity field or you used you
know because electromagnetics are
becoming bigger and bigger and bigger
you know catapults on ships were steam
powered and the new gerald ford is
electromagnetic
roller coasters used to use a chain to
get you to the top of the hill now they
shoot you with electromagnetics and
you're going
so there's a whole new realm of
propulsion that you know sometimes it's
our ability to develop the technology to
support theory
you know we are just now proving you
know recently
theories that einstein had where people
actually joked about them and now we
actually have the technology to prove
that gravity can bend light
you know we have proven that so you look
at that when you go well does that mean
that you know
70 years ago einstein was wrong or eight
years ago einstein was wrong or do you
go
we just didn't have the ability to look
that deep into space to actually find
something that we could
to actually measure and you know what
i've seen and that's just a hundred
years
and and the kind of things that can
happen if you say look what we've done
in the last 20 years yeah it's crazy
you